if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
on in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water
rushes out to sea because people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times
as opposed to once all right welcome
everybody
what an exciting day truly truly
something to be
you know the only really exciting things
going on right now
i would say are space exploration
vaccines and watching bitcoin i mean
honestly like what else is there right
now and uh we are standing by look at
that
absolutely perfectly timed the landing
of the
nasa perseverance mars rover
scheduled for today the actual landing
time
is an hour and 40 minutes from now now i
know or 35 35.
wait no uh 40. yeah um a lot of people
i think are going to be interested in
this and i'm so glad to to have
something uh positive to cover
we're going to learn about the
perseverance rover we may even take your
phone calls we're continuing on with the
earlier stream instead of starting at
zero we're already starting at 24.
so hopefully we'll open up some phone
lines as we wait for the landing i think
it's going to be
a great great afternoon it is uh an
except or morning
if depending or night depending on where
you're joining us i guess
uh all right it looks like the program
here is about to start
and we want to make sure whoa
wow perseverance of humanity launching
the next generation of robotic explorers
to the red planet by the way how amazing
is it that joe biden got us to mars in
under a month as president
isn't that unbelievable that's just it
it's really really incredible
uh no i'm kidding obviously the the
perseverance rover was launched in july
of 2020.
it had nothing to do with trump nor joe
biden that's just a joke
uh hapa says anyone truly interested in
planets
astrology you mean astronomy right or
maybe you do mean astrology okay anyone
truly interested in planets astrology
space station satellite activity can't
name them all here
should get the skyview app really
amazing yes
let's see what's happening welcome to
nasa's jet propulsion laboratory
in southern california we are gearing up
for nasa's perseverance rover to touch
down on mars
happening in an hour and a half from now
the rover will attempt to land in
jezreel crater
it is the most difficult landing site on
mars ever
attempted thank you for joining us i'm
your host
raquel villanueva in the past
mission team members gathered in our
mission control for landings wow
but this time around we have coveted
safety measures in place
today's landing will look a little
different than what you've seen before
i am in a room by myself and so is my
co-host
here in the space flight operations
facility
team members are in different parts of
this building
some are in mission control others are
upstairs for
landing operations we also have isolated
rooms for our guests on this show
love it in total we have eight locations
covered by
14 robotic cameras that you will be
seeing
one of those locations is the dark room
the heart of nasa's deep space network
think of it as a giant communication
switchboard
this is where spacecraft phone home to
us from across the solar system
and interstellar space the deep space
network has been tracking perseverance
since it left earth and there are lots
of ways you can watch
landing today we have a 360 degree
camera
inside the control room it lets you
experience the landing
right along with the team while seeing
this broadcast
we also have the clean feed it shows an
uninterrupted view of mission control
and audio
clean tambien tenemos
tell us about it is host diana trujillo
who also works on the mission
thank you raquel we're so excited to be
the sister live broadcast in spanish
synthony program twitter
youtube and facebook
and don't forget we want to see how you
are watching the landing today
use the hashtag countdown to mars to
send us your photos and videos
to preview what interviews are coming up
is my co-host from the jpl news office
marine so this is great stuff so since
we have time let's get some background
on the mars rover now of course anytime
we talk about mars we are required
required to play this historic american
moment where donald trump brought the
world together by announcing if he were
to get a second term we would go
to nars remember this
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars there it is
donald trump doing what no one else was
willing to do
telling us we would go to nars
under his leadership and uh a shame that
we didn't get that opportunity
but mars is going to have to do
the perseverance rover we actually
actually have a lot of um
informational elements here perseverance
nicknamed percy
is a car-sized rover designed to explore
jezreel crater manufactured by the jpl
launched on 30 july 2020
scheduled to land today 3 55
pm eastern time that's 20 55
utc it carries seven specific
instruments and boasts braggadociously a
total of 19 cameras and two microphones
uh the rover one of those microphones is
always on speakerphone that's the only
thing we have to remember so when we
start getting audio back it is going to
be really annoying like when i take
phone calls one of the microphones
always on speaker
the rover carrying the helicopter
ingenuity
an experimental aircraft that will
attempt
the first powered flight on another
planet this
is really exciting stuff the helicopter
is in the rover the rover will land
and then we will have a chopper on mars
can you imagine so this is going to be
um this is going to be very very
exciting this was not
cheap nasa plans to invest 2.75 billion
over 11 years
including 2.2 billion for the
development and build of the hardware
243 million for launch 291 million for
operating the missions for two and a
half years
this inflation adjusted is nasa's
sixth most expensive robotic planetary
mission
cheaper than its predecessor the
curiosity rover
what a day what a day and we are
standing by now about one hour and 34
minutes away
from the scheduled landing reportedly
they are going to pay
for some of this with doji coin as we
heard from a republican member of
congress earlier
during the robin hood hearings which i
am still monitoring by the way
it really was going nowhere it really
was going nowhere but
doji coin always in play
always in play and something that uh we
we might be looking at at some point in
the future all right let's see what's on
everybody's minds here
uh glad to be tuning in via cyber for
the
nars coverage and elements of space yeah
we are delivering today's
presentations cyberly and i'm glad that
that's going on
carpetbagger wants to know if i've yet
acquainted myself with gritty i have not
fred says hello from france uh very much
appreciate that caleb horn says hello
from league city texas my power came
back on last night
good longest three days of my life
huddled around the fireplace during that
time no broken pipes
and we moved our fridge outside to save
food
horrible what is going on and uh
unfortunately
your senator ted cruz is in cancun
in cancun mexico and our friend aaron
rupar at vox has been following this
ted cruz once he got caught fleeing the
u.s for mexico
claimed that he was just going for like
20 hours
and that's a lot of luggage for 20 hours
i don't know
i mean listen i i pack basically the
same for three days as for 14 days
i bring a rollerboard and a backpack but
20 hours i don't think i need that much
stuff so then
uh wait what was the statement they put
out here is the statement with school
cancelled for the week our girls
asked to take a trip with friends
wanting to be a good dad
i flew down with them last night and am
flying back this afternoon my staff and
i
are in constant communication blah blah
blah blah blah
um fox was able to confirm that ted cruz
did travel to cancun
what a clown what an absolute and total
clown
uh but that is the latest with ted cruz
so i'm glad to hear that you are uh
that that your power is back on let's
see if i can also find the nasa
clean feed here is the nasa clean
feed the feed we have here is very very
dirty
so we also want the clean feed so we
have all feeds this one
includes presentations from nasa this is
just the clean feed of mission control
so we have all feeds all the time for
our viewers
and uh we're going to keep an eye on all
of this very
very interesting stuff okay other super
chats coming in david thanks for
covering this nasa is the most one of
the most important things the government
does progress in
space flight is progress as a species
absolutely
it's a mars hess truck right it carries
its own chopper
do you use hairline retention pills or
something like that what's your opinion
on that
kind of stuff no you know i am actually
starting to think that that
i may be having problems with my hair
i'm looking very very closely when i
shower
i start to think that right here it's
not that it's receding i've always
had this hairline but i'm starting to
wonder if this front area
is getting a little bit sparse and
uh but no i've to date i've not used any
of these elements
my brother is completely bald he went
bald at age 20.
so as you can imagine it is not the most
exciting thing to see that and then
wonder what's going on
but uh no i'm keeping a very close eye
on it i have no
moral issues uh with any kind of hair
retention
techniques or products whatsoever but i
have not
availed myself of them at this time
david i'm here for quatto's reveal on
nars
yeah i'm standing by for it evolutionary
biologist here working in the field of
astrobiology
today's just another step towards
finding some extraterrestrials already
well it's exciting in many ways here's
simon cowell's brother who apparently is
a high high
highly placed operative in the
perseverance rover
that's a joke by the way chakaseki asks
is there anyone ted won't throw under
the bus first his wife his father and
now his kids
yeah ted's a disgusting disgusting guy
huge thank you to betsy fate brother
betsy fate brother just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and hassan choib also signing up at
joinpakman.com those are new members
25 and 26 and the coupon code is in play
it is absolutely in play today
uh all right we have a view of what's
happening at the jet propulsion
laboratory
at cal institute of technology this is a
medium light roast people asking about
my coffee
okay let's let's see uh hear what's
going on at nasa
whether they're ready to turn off the
transmitter to perseverance
turning off the transmitter is like
taking
your hands off of the wheel at this
point ford perseverance would be
on her own to execute entry descent
landing over 500
000 lines of code let's listen in
okay and we just uh seem to have lost
video
the clean feed is working fine so it
appears to be on their end and not
ours that's very interesting
to perseverance turning off the
transmitter
is like taking your hands off of the
wheel
this is weird point forward perseverance
would be on her own
to execute entry descent and landing
is it gonna freeze again let's listen in
oh my god it looks like they're having a
problem
yeah that's a real problem well we've
got the clean feed over here let's see
if there's audio on it
propulsion oh they're back
while this feed having major problems
let's switch to the clean feed for now
which is very low
chief is go project manager
project go mission manager all stations
are go for transmitter off
wow copy flight go for transmitter off
ace flight flight is go ahead
please perform the transmitter off at
1935 utc
one back on that wow patients note that
this action will force the sdst
into one weight coherent mode loss of
telemetry for less than 90 seconds is
expected
oh well this is ted three permission to
stop sharing
tattoo you're gonna have to speak up
sorry oh well this is task three
permission to stop sharing
oh yes sorry uh so yes you can stop
sharing thank you for putting that up
oil one this is tad one go did you say
chad one that's interesting
uh okay looks like they are back up and
running here the sample return phase in
which we're
not only looking around looking at the
geology
but really turning our rower into a
robotic geologist and astrobiologist
collecting samples that we will bring
back to earth and for us of course those
are where the best laboratories are
of all of humanity some of them still
remain to be explored by some that are
not yet
in the science community yet and that's
what we're looking forward to it's that
new face the other element that i want
to talk about is the
amazing technologies that are there and
of course one of my favorites is the
ingenuity helicopter this in search of
this extraterrestrial
chopper first moment you know controlled
flight for the first time
elsewhere raquel great and we have
a student question on video for you from
macy
hi my name is macy ragsdale my question
is is anything alive on mars
thank you well amazing i'm so glad
for your question that's a question i
ask myself is anything alive there and
frankly
at the surface where we're going right
now with uh perseverance
we do not believe there's anything alive
uh
right there because of the radiation
that's there it's chilling cold and
there's really no water there but guess
what
we think that three billion years ago
this
looked like a stream that you may see on
earth and frankly a lot more similar
than earth with water with a magnetic
field just like the earth with an
atmosphere
and the question was she's going to
reclaim her time
she wanted a yes or no answer on that
one and she is certainly not uh
not not getting it um the only caravan
in mexico i'm worried about are the cruz
family well said
q says the martians rigged the election
they're also asking for donations to
build a space wall around earth to keep
out martian caravans
do you think we'll find ted hiding on
mars after running from the media in
cancun a lot of mars ted cruz stories
being put together
is there any oh we already got that one
from chakaseki very very nice
um yeah this is this is this is really
exciting stuff this is the forefront of
human ingenuity and science and uh
pushing the limits of
uh what what humans as a species have
done
so we've got quite a day quite quite a
day ahead of us
this is a nasa feed involving interviews
and different commentary
we also have as a backup a clean feed as
i like to call it
where we will be able to switch if there
are continued problems
with the commentary feed and the
commentary feed will dip in and out of
of that clean feed so a lot of exciting
stuff going on and if you're just
joining us we are down to
the last hour and 24 minutes before the
scheduled
landing of the perseverance rover on
mars this rover was launched on july
30th 2020
and it will it is scheduled to land in
an hour and 23 minutes and nasa
uh has the unique ability to schedule
landings a year in advance
down to the minute very interesting and
this not not a year in this case uh six
months
six months in advance did i hear about
the new former mayor the now former
mayor of colorado city texas
politicians and power generation
companies owe you nothing
yeah we covered that yesterday on the
award-winning bonus show
awards we give out but they're awards
nonetheless
and uh it the guy is the guy's a joke
and i'm glad to see that he has indeed
resigned
and that's a good thing that is a very
very good thing thanks to mueller probe
as well as hitachi
deflated brady and many others for the
twitch subs
uh six of you have signed up i really
appreciate that and that puts us at 32
since we have a little while until the
scheduled landing i have
made the offer made the commitment to
open phone lines if we achieve our
goal of 100. getting us a little bit
closer is lucas
sorensen lucas just signed up at
joinpakman.com
and excitingly lucas used the coupon
code better21
to sign up lucas's new member number 33.
now what percentage we're at 33 out of
100. let me do the
okay three divided by ten point zero
carry through
33 that's 33 percent of the weight of
the goal
and putting us solidly in play solidly
in play
i think to achieve that number
follow perseverance on its journey to
the surface of the red planet
with eyes on the solar system from your
desktop or mobile device
go to eyes.nasa.gov click on the banner
and now you're with perseverance in real
time
through every step of edl entry
descent and landing this interactive
experience
lets you ride along from whatever
perspective you choose
click and drag scroll in scroll out
check out the descriptions and
explanations to increase your edl
expertise experience every entry descent
and landing event
very exciting perseverance safely on
mars
the eyes experience is based on
predictive data
but during this broadcast you'll see a
different visualization
called ranger and it's based on the real
communication the team and mission
control receives
from perseverance in near real time
this is the visualization the team will
follow as data fills their screens while
monitoring the health of perseverance
on its nerve wracking course to another
successful
so this is going to be quite quite uh a
presentation i am very excited to see
exactly uh what happens here uh mission
control in california at jpl
very attentively following what is now a
uh
a trip of many months that is down to
its last
hour and 20 minutes hour and 20 minutes
remaining
and it is going to be a great thing
daniel says if conservatives are against
globalists what will their attack be on
the
solar systemists involved with today's
events
i tend not to care what right-wingers
say about
this type of stuff they don't accept
climate science
they don't accept virus science many not
all why do i care what they say about
about space science
if you could narrow it down what do you
think the root of the rights
fear-mongering about trans people in
particular is i think the
the root at its core is religiously
based but
even non-religious right-wingers have
just sort of taken it as an
opportunity to attack the left for what
they describe as woke-ism
uh and even if they are not personally
religious caleb just described the
republican mission statement
is this the neil degrasse tyson super
bowl yes
that's exactly what this is
that's exactly what this is let's see
someone claiming to be former producer
lewis is in the twitch chat let me see
if this is
uh oh that's an insta-ban yep they
create louis has a streaming account
they created their account five minutes
ago so that's an insta-ban that's too
bad they almost got away with it
but no lewis has a real account on
twitch
and uh that is not actually lewis so
we've ban hammered them
very very exciting it's like people
manage to get banned no matter what i'm
doing
no matter what i'm doing people manage
to get themselves banned it's it's
really unbelievable
uh all right let's listen in finally you
may also hear
tango delta nominal or touchdown nominal
that means we've touched down on the
surface of mars
within the expected range of safe
landing speeds
thanks for that breakdown now this is
your first mars mission
what have you learned from this
experience yeah one of my takeaways is
that you can almost never be too careful
when it comes to mars you definitely
can't
take mars for granted you know we've
checked and double checked and triple
checked everything
on our way to mars and um you know even
though we've done this once before
using the sky crane technique on the
curiosity
rover um you know i think everyone's
going to have
their uh everyone's going to hold their
breath until we're on the surface of
mars this time around
and we have a social media question
coming in nor the door on instagram asks
how complicated is the automated landing
sequence
and who wrote the code yeah it's quite
complicated uh the automated landing
software needs to do literally hundreds
of things all
on its own just right with sub second
timing accuracy
and it's the result of many hundreds of
people
over many years stretching all the way
back to curiosity and then uh
improved for the perseverance landing
today at jezreel crater
great thanks for your time today matt
and good luck supposedly the people who
wrote who coded grand theft auto had a
big role to play in the
landing today that's a joke by the way
that's a joke
um yeah i'm just kidding around about
that
just a joke david have you heard of the
documentarian adam curtis he has a new
bbc series about how society has become
polarized highly recommend i've heard of
him
i'm not familiar with the documentary
but it sounds
very interesting very very interesting
and i would be interested in
looking at that if you were just joining
us
today is the day where the perseverance
rover which launched on the 30th of july
last year
lands on mars well this is a little bit
of an eric the actor vibe from uh howard
stern fame did you guys see that that's
interesting
i'm scheduled for landing at 3 55 p.m
eastern that's just an
hour and 17 now an hour and 16 minutes
from now
the uh entire process is going to be
visible to us through this nasa feed
and it's extraordinarily exciting to see
and uh we will all see it we will all
see it
uh mission control feed let's see what's
happening here
very calm everybody's very calm
and nasa seemingly having bandwidth
issues on all feeds we've seen both
feeds have problems although not at the
same time
and people in the chat reporting ah here
was the launch people in the chat
reporting they're experiencing the same
thing it does not appear to be my
bandwidth issue it appears to be a nasa
bandwidth issue plain and simple
this landing gives me the expanse vibes
have you heard of it of course
of course uh i interviewed one of the
writers of the expanse
and i saw season one although that's
where i stopped
if people are interesting interested in
some good
mars fiction i recently
read the first of three books in kim
stanley robinson's mars trilogy the
first one is called red
mars and i read that not long ago
it's not a new book uh the entire
trilogy has been out for a while
but i will be reading both sequels soon
really really great
trilogy of books i want to say thanks to
douglas chambers douglas just grabbed a
membership at joinpackman.com douglas i
really appreciate your support today
and this is stream number two for the
day and a lot of exciting things going
on
for people curious the robin hood
hearings are still going on
let's just take a brief listen just just
a small
dip in to see what's happening that is i
know numbers of people
personal friends who have never invested
before but because of robin hood and
other retail platforms many of them took
the stimulus money
that they received during the cares act
which they were still working they
didn't need and they actually started an
account
and started investing so yes more and
more people who seem to be crickets in
the background
are now investing using these platforms
um
this hearing is a reminder that with
complex situations
we should take time to understand what
actually did
or did not happen especially with this
gamestop situation
now the sec is the proper authority to
determine if any rules were broken
and they are looking into it congress
has already given the sec
broad authority all right so mostly just
rather than questions
speeches from members of congress
continuing on
and we are going to uh we are going to
keep an eye on that but really we are
here
because of the perseverance rover just a
reminder because it's so funny remember
a uh innovative and um
a forward-looking donald trump promised
to go to nars
if he were re-elected
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars now we're
not doing that today but we do have
something i think that's almost as
exciting which is that we are landing
the perseverance rover on mars
bringing its own helicopter with it if
you can imagine
and that is just an hour and 13 minutes
away an hour and 13 minutes away
really really incredible stuff okay
uh let's see do i have any ban
adjudications to do i do
i have one um by popular demand i've
ordered a
uh not a mallet what am i talking about
a gavel
that i will be banging when adjudicating
twitch
unban requests in the future i don't
have it yet
but i will have it next week in the
meantime i do have someone
who wants to be unbanned this is a user
whose recent messages are and you guys
can help me adjudicate this
trump 2020 obama dropped blankets
trump 2020 best presidential address
i've ever seen
usa usa trump 2020 nancy needs another
xanax
steal your president trump 20 24 more
years
sore losers [ __ ] and then they were
banned
after that their unban request is simply
lmao so that's not even a serious unban
request that is going to be
denied and that is adjudicated a
perma-ban
on the david pakman show twitch channel
that is it um the fake
louis motomety um
fake louis motomety wants to be unbanned
uh
former known disorder triggered
my knit they're claiming that their real
name is louis motomety but it's not the
former producer
this is just a perma-ban guys it's just
that that's just it it's ridiculous
um okay anyway while we listen i'm just
gonna text louis just to ensure that's
not him i don't know if he's trolling
which are great for the science
community that's the type of features
they're looking for to learn more about
mars
but they're all landing hazards for us
uh and so
we've had to add new technology uh
navigation which is the ability
essentially to divert away from hazards
uh and but we have taken this system
through
the same types of paces that we have in
previous missions we've used the same
techniques the same uh best practices
for engineering verification
and many these audio streams are
terrible
terrible terrible terrible nasa really
having tech issues here and it's really
too bad
because it's just not good and i'm
seeing the chat even on the nasa stream
and everybody's saying that it's
insanely laggy
okay louis confirming that he was not in
the chat okay
someone someone
impersonating
and we banned them but then
i wondered if it was
actually you all right that was not
producer lewis so that is going to be a
uh permaban lewis would never be caught
dead watching me on twitch that's what
people need to understand
instead of a gavel can you do some light
judge dread
i don't know about that cryptogems okay
yeah we're not promoting crypto
yeah we're not doing that this land oh
we already did that one okay good
all right so no no relevant uh or
informative super chats at this point
to uh take a look at and that's
absolutely and totally fine
thanks to tom the tomb for the twitch
prime sub
very much appreciate that joe
says greetings from portugal and germany
we love your show keep on going david
thank you it's it's such an exciting day
to uh to be here
and we are down to the last hour before
this landing takes place
i think it's going to be amazing i think
it will go off
without a hitch i don't anticipate any
problems i know there's a lot of
disaster porners
who are they seem to almost like hope
something goes wrong
but i think it's good going to be
absolutely fine i don't expect any
issues at all
daraten says the problem with the nasa
site is in the name.gov
okay ferret queen says keep it a mallet
and call it whack a troll
shion says i'm filibustering the next
troy york vote
two-thirds required that's an
interesting idea lately we've been
putting up whether i should play troll
voicemails up to a vote and i've been
doing it by simple majority
but we could say that we it really
should be 60
support or 67 support we could do that
what we would need to do is have a vote
as to what the percentage should be and
then it becomes infinitely
regressive because then we should vote
as to whether there should be a vote
to decide what the threshold would be
and then we'll be here for for the rest
of time
uh david are you interested in going on
the first all civilian
flight crew for spacex's inspiration
for anyone can go with a donation to
saint jude's
let's look into that spacex
um inspiration for
saint jude donation let's see what's up
with that
no no it's enter to win a seat it's not
anybody can go it's enter to win a seat
that's a totally different thing
david any chance of a wireless access
point breakdown
while we wait show shapiro who the real
og beta male is yes i know i know
i second the judge dread idea and
weaselways
sending a twenty dollar super chat i
very much uh very much appreciate that
should i do the show live from space
yeah maybe
that's not a bad idea thanks to alexis
castillo
for signing up at joinpackman.com you
are new member number 35 today
and also thanks to our five additional
twitch subscribers
we're at 40. people demanding phone
lines be opened i
i am open i i'm open to opening phone
lines before the landing the landing is
still
67 minutes away but we do have a goal of
a hundred website members and twitch
subs and i'm not going to relent on that
i'm not going to relent on that because
uh you know then it's
you just can't you can't i lose
credibility if i do that
it took a lot of refreshing to get the
nasa's eyes website to work
irritating but once you get it it's
totally worth it let's see nasa eyes
let's see if we can get that going
that's another
uh visual element that nasa is providing
oh download an app uh i'm not gonna i
don't think i'm gonna download an app
right now
oh okay so a lot of things going wrong
there yeah we're gonna stay away from
that
we're gonna stay away from that don't
worry we're gonna have plenty of uh
interesting views and
and things here mars is the only planet
we know of
populated only by robots and we put them
there
i suppose that's true i suppose that
that's absolutely accurate
at least that the government is public
about
that's uh that's a more conspiratorial
approach
to high frequency or uhf signals from
perseverance
these orbiters relay these signals to
deep space network stations on earth
madrid in spain and goldstone in
california
the mars reconnaissance orbiter or mro
has reconfigured its software to perform
a type of relay called bent pipe
this will provide us with near real-time
telemetry during entry descent and
landings right we have coverage from the
mars reconnaissance orbiter
from just before entry to a few minutes
after landing
the telemetry we receive will be delayed
by the time it takes light to travel
from mars
to us back on earth additionally the
mars atmosphere and volatile evolution
spacecraft or maven
is recording these uhf signals and will
be relaying that recording hours
after landing wow haven will be covering
us from around the time of cruise stage
separation
until a few minutes after landing we
also receive what we call heartbeat
tones
which are indications that the
spacecraft is alive and progressing
throughout entry descent and landing
it's important to note that while
unexpected
we could lose our communication lengths
and still land safely
because perseverance is doing entry
descent and landing completely
autonomously
she doesn't need our help to joystick
the landing the communication links give
us added visibility
wow and you can see chloe hard at work
inside mission control right now
perseverance's landing
might look like the system the curiosity
rover used back in 2012.
let's take a look yeah people are
recommending the mark rober video
of the up close on the rover let's see
if we can look at a little bit of that
uh where do they actually go and look at
it let's see here
uh where is the up close
does he actually get to the let's see
here oh
it doesn't it's not clear that he
actually goes and looks at it in person
hmm oh wait is this hold on here we go
responsibility this is the rover the
flight rover it will be on mars
12 months from now wow so complex when
you come up
and get this close in fact perseverance
is the most complex thing humans have
ever built and sent to another planet
it's got laser
x-ray and radar capabilities plus 19
cameras and a nuclear-powered battery
system for energy
and while it might look pretty similar
to the past rover curiosity all the
science instruments are completely
different because the science objectives
have changed the most notable difference
is this time the drill isn't there just
to create rock dust to study on the
rover perseverance has a hollow drill
bit to core out a chunk of rock the size
of a piece of chalk
and then package it up and leave behind
43 separate samples for a future mission
to collect and send back to earth
that way we can study the samples for
those past signs of life using the most
state-of-the-art instruments on earth
that we could never fit on a rover so
then to capture that chalk size rock
sample not only is there an arm on the
outside but this time there's one on the
inside too
it is a miniature robot arm inside the
body of the rover
that manipulates the sample tube and
there's one right here
wow and so is this what you leave behind
exactly is it fair to say this is like
the poop of the rover
exactly do you like that analogy because
they didn't like it earlier
yeah you like it would you like to say
that the rover is gonna poop outside
okay good see that's a good analogy so
perseverance is really only the first
leg of returning a piece of mars to
earth
future missions will complete what i
like to call the poop scoop and shoot
maneuver this is my friend liz by the
way and she's in charge of all the
testing for the sample retrieval system
we're doing things that nobody else does
so we have to test it so she tests
all sorts of different configurations in
a chamber that recreates the extreme
temperatures and pressures
to make sure it will function on mars
because once you send something to space
it's gone and you can't exactly fix it
so it just has to work which is why
testing is such a big deal here at jpl
my buddy matt here
mentioned another way this is done so we
build two spacecraft one that goes to
mars and one that we keep here on earth
to test
and this is an exact replica of
curiosity who's driving around on mars
right now and then we use this one to
test
driving around obstacles and driving
over rocks and he knows a thing or two
about driving over rocks because he was
a rover driver for both wow
opportunity and curiosity this guy is
like one of maybe
40 people in the world who has driven a
vehicle on another planet
which is it's kind of a big deal and so
a few more cool things about
perseverance are that it has a mini
helicopter drone stowed away on its
underbelly there it is
this will be mankind's first powered
flight on another planet which sort of
makes this a wright brothers moment and
the rover and the drone will get great
footage of each other but we're mainly
testing it out so that in the future we
might use drones to scout out terrain
for us or get samples from hard to reach
locations or you could have
swarms of drones carrying materials for
humans from one site to another
perseverance is also testing out a new
instrument called moxie that basically
amounts to a mechanical tree because its
function
is to convert co2 into oxygen which
future explorers will need to breathe
and for rockets interesting tests
i've been in this clean room for about a
year and a half starting as just
a chassis just the skeleton and then all
the teams and engineers have been taking
turns coming down and building up their
part until it's done
in fact i was in that exact position on
curiosity designing my hardware for
about three and a half years
and when it was all tested and complete
integrating it on the rover
right here in this room and then for the
other three and a half years like i
mentioned before i was working with ben
on a small team of engineers on the
jetpack descent stage so now we've
covered the where
and the why we're going also the how
we're gonna do all that with the rover
now let's talk about the what for what's
going to happen this thursday when it
lands and what you should expect to see
as i edit this video the spacecraft is
gliding toward mars at a cool
48 144 miles per hour strong speed
it's this fast it's 15 times faster than
a bullet it's traveling the length of a
hundred soccer fields in exactly this
long
and it will keep on that trajectory
until the big moment on thursday when it
starts its entry descent and landing or
edl
it's also known as the seven minutes of
tear because we've literally got seven
minutes to get from the top of the
atmosphere to the surface of mars
going from 13 000 miles per hour to zero
in perfect sequence and perfect timing
and the spacecraft has to do it all on
its own
with no help from us on earth when it
first hits the upper atmosphere the
friction causes
the heat shield to start glowing like
the surface of the sun all the while
thrusters are firing
to steer and adjust its course towards
the target location and that aero
breaking gets rid of 99
of the energy so for the last one
percent we deploy a supersonic parachute
then we've gotta pop off the heat shield
we no longer need like removing the lens
cap so the process
start viewing the ground but even with
the parachute it's still traveling 200
miles per hour which is way too fast to
land and so that's where we cut loose of
the back shell
and fire the rockets but we can't quite
land in this configuration because the
rockets will pick up too much debris and
damage the rover so then we lower it
from a 21 foot rope and gently land the
rover
wow as my sky crane zooms off to face an
honorable catastrophic ending
as far away from the rover as it's
remaining you imagine and so in just
seven minutes the spacecraft has
completely metamorphosed yeah people
what this is what's going to happen in
50
58 minutes this is the process that's
about to start or
i guess really in 51 minutes if it's a
seven minute process
shedding all its sacrificial elements
until you're left with just a rover
sitting alone safely on the surface of
mars now everything you just saw was a
cgi animation but a few days after
landing we'll all be blown away by
actual hd landing footage from the 23
cameras and two microphones on board
we'll see the parachute inflate and hear
the crunch of the aluminum wheels
as they touch down and make contact with
the martian surface
and because mars is so far away to get a
signal from the vehicle to our planet
it takes about 12 minutes at the speed
of light so that means
after the spacecraft sends a signal that
has reached the top of the atmosphere
by the time that signal reaches earth to
kick off the seven minutes of tear
for at least five minutes the vehicle
has actually already been on the surface
or dead which is why it has to be
autonomous that means it makes all its
own choices on the exact timing of
things and where to steer
without anyone from earth controlling it
which means all we can do is watch
and monitor and hope fascinating
fascinating stuff and that's what awaits
us just uh
really just just moments from now i mean
we are
standing by now scheduled landing is 57
minutes from now and
we are going to watch all of it happen
it is all coming up
very very soon i'm glad that so many
people are with us
i want to say thanks to zach watkins
zack just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com and his new member
number 41 today
today is a beautiful perfect day to grab
a membership
on my website um andrew quoting
a great former president trump saying
mars of which
the moon is a part yeah let's see i
that's actually a good one let's see if
i can find that
trump uh mars moon
i like that one uh
one no that one's not it
mars moon a part
is that one on video now i don't
remember
i would advance beyond that and i
thought either with target mars or or
why this wine nope that's not it
he may not have actually said that on
video
you've wrote mars is part of the moon so
hard on the kidney very special
the kidney has a very special place
in the heart it's an incredible thing uh
people that have to go this people that
have loved ones that
are are working so hard to stay alive
they have to work
so hard there's a there's an esprit de
corps there's a spirit
like you see rarely on anything so i
just want to thank all of you folks for
being here it's really
fantastic i guess this is a different
clip
you've been work you've worked so hard
so maybe we don't have to do we know did
he
say the moon and mars are a part of it i
don't even know if that's actually on
video
yeah it's not here maybe it's not
something he ever actually said on video
i think it was a tweet actually if i'm
recalling now i think it was a tweet
anyway okay um that's okay
no big deal everything's fine
everything's fine
other super chats coming in are ted cruz
and his kids on board
i think only ted cruz is coming back
from cancun today
uh yeah as far as i know it's just ted
yeah that's a whole other story i don't
know if you guys have been following it
but ted cruz fled texas yesterday while
his constituents were without power
to go to cancun he got caught and then
he claimed he was just going for a few
hours
but he had a lot of luggage a lot of
luggage for a 20-hour trip
and it's all it's all quite weaponized
let me put it that way no no shortage of
weaponization there but he should be we
know he was standing by on the
uh upgrade list for business class
so apparently he's going to be coming
back very very soon
uh mika wants to know whether i've read
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
yes i have by douglas adams i have read
that
great it's a it's not like my favorite
to be perfectly frank but
a good book a good book it's just not my
i'm not that into like
comedy books i guess i would say
and there's a strong comedic element to
it i've never been as into the the
you know kind of comedy science fiction
but
uh not a bad book at all as we stand by
all right a lot of people are joining
and wondering what's going on
here's what's going on um
we are waiting for the
cure not the curiosity the follow-up to
the curiosity rover the perseverance
rover
to land on mars that is scheduled for
53 minutes from now 53 minutes from now
it is scheduled to land on mars now
because of the 12-minute
delay that's how long it takes light to
get from mars to earth
uh we may not know or we will not know
um
for that long what exactly happened
but we will eventually know and that's
what matters all right
okay um
live simulation with sensor data let's
take a look at that
we've got uh let's take a look at what
we've got here
oh this is compelling
this says touchdown is only 16 minutes
away is that right i thought it was so i
guess they're running ahead of schedule
uh live oh no no no touchdown in 51. oh
that was a simulation i see
okay so live is we are 51 minutes away
the next phase will be d spin in 36
minutes this is this is great stuff
this is absolutely great stuff
live telemetry my friends live telemetry
yeah they were able to make up a little
bit of time with a tailwind that's
exactly right
okay excellent excellent 3 55 pm eastern
time is the scheduled landing and we are
getting very close to that very close to
that thank you to joe biden
that he got us to mars so quickly no
other president would have been able to
do it
that's a joke everybody relax please
relax
please people are getting really mad at
me
big thanks to brandon quintana
who is new member number 42 today
signing up at
joinpackman.com
howard says if you want a mind trip
watch why the speed of light can't be
measured
by veritasium it's not actually 12
minutes from mars we cannot
we actually cannot know for sure what
the one-way speed of light is
i've read about that i've read about
that before yeah
could you provide a list of david
pakman's must-read favorite books at
least a few suggestions you know it's so
difficult because
i just read so so much but a few things
i've read recently
um let's see i recently read
i read machines machines like us
wait what's it called it's by ian
hold on machines like
me machines like me by ian mcewen
tremendous book absolutely tremendous
book
i recently read uh the first
of the murder bot diaries by martha
wells
i recently read the silent patient by
alex michelidis
it's good it's a very quick read that's
fiction from the standpoint of fiction
non-fiction i'm reading meth land right
now i recently read homicide by david
simon both are kind of narrative
non-fiction investigative type books
both very good
some good uh personal finance recently i
recently read
um what a hillbilly elegy by j.d vance
and i'm going to try to
get jd on the program it would be very
interesting to have him on the show
did i hear rush limbaugh died yesterday
you know i didn't hear that
no i didn't hear that i'm gonna have to
how could i have missed that
really shocking did i see where lindsey
graham said lara trump was the future of
the republican party
i didn't let's see if i can find that
gram
lara trump future
um and we can't let that ever
happen again senator is governor haley
wrong about donald trump's future in the
republican party
uh yeah donald trump is the most vibrant
member of the republican party
the trump movement is alive and well
people believe that he brought change to
washington
policy-wise it was long overdue all i
can say
is that the most potent force in the
republican party is president trump
we need trump plus and at the end of the
day
i've been involved in politics for over
25 years
uh the president is a handful and what
happened on january 6 was terrible for
the country
but he's a handful talking like he's a
kid you have to manage not singularly to
blame democrats have sit on the
sidelines
and watch the country be burned down
democrats were partially to
blame for january 6th year and a half
and that said a damn word
and most republicans are tired of the
hypocrisy so no
nikki's wrong about president trump uh
north carolina the biggest winner i
think
of this whole impeachment trial is laura
trump my dear friend richard burr who i
like and
have been friends to a long time just
made laura trump
almost a certain nominee for the senate
seat in north carolina to replace him if
she runs
and i'll certainly will be behind her
because i think she represents
the future of the republican party wow
yeah that's
that's pretty vile thanks for calling
that to my attention that's
highly highly weaponized extremely
weaponized
scary to the guy who liked the
veritasium video try pbs spacetime the
origin of mass and time it will change
your life
david d spins continuously see what i
did there
okay all right
um very very good we actually are on the
precipice of two milestones today
not only are we um 47 minutes
from the landing of the mars
perseverance rover
on mars we are only
86 twitch followers away from 80
000. can you imagine two major
milestones coming together
uh on on exactly the same day
shocking shocking stuff did it touch
done yet and all these republicans
beside the good ones like hogan need to
get voting out
right no it didn't touch down yet we are
standing by for touchdown
down to 46 minutes from
touchdown we are now 6600 miles from the
landing site i think i'm able to rotate
this
i've been told yes look at that
i'm rotating the rover it is soon going
to de-spin
boy this website is laggy um 6 500 miles
from the landing site
4 600 miles of elevation traveling at
about 8
000 miles per hour a touchdown is in 46
minutes and we will enter the d
spin phase in only 30 minutes
30 minutes so a lot happening and it is
all happening before our eyes
uh very exciting this is mission control
and uh that is it
that is it we are about to enter the no
spin zone
trish says time to move out of north
carolina yeah if lara trump uh
is is the senator that's not going to be
a great place to be
that's for sure i would i would be
really looking
strongly as the kids these days say
at moving out of north carolina
no question about it all right let's
listen to the coverage
thing we've ever sent into space
now this is a very complicated campaign
can you break down for us
how it's going to work and if there's
any international partners working with
us
you are correct the donations
in fact it's probably the most
challenging thing we've ever tried to do
but we're definitely not going to try
and do it alone we have
great partners with the european space
agency
and the way this campaign is going to
work well perseverance is the first step
chapter one is going to mars and
collecting the samples
chapter two is going to be a sample
return
lander that we hope to launch in around
26 to 28 2026 to 2028
and that lander it'll be an american
lander carrying
a fetch rover that's provided by
european space agency
and that little fetch rover will drive
out and pick up the samples that
perseverance left on the surface of mars
and the fetch river will bring them back
and load them into a rocket that we call
the mars ascent vehicle which will be
the first ever launch from another
planet
and it will launch those samples into
orbit around mars
in the meantime european space agency
will have an
orbiter that's in order that's funny
people are asking for a countdown to 80
000 twitch subs as well we could
we actually can do that uh youtube got
rid of the live
follower count in the sense that it only
updates every thousand or now that we're
over a million only every 10
000 but we have a live twitch follower
account we are counting down to the
perseverance rover on mars
and we are counting down to 80 000
followers
on twitch extraordinarily exciting
and something that we can control in
real time and observe in real time no
no light speed delay the way we have
with the perseverance rover
uh very very exciting stuff
people telling me also to make sure not
to miss the separation yes we have the
we are down to a uh oh hold on d spin
yeah d spin in 27 minutes landing in 43
i'm guessing that the nasa feed is going
to have that live
as well we've got a lot going on there
um but yes tracking our way oh people
unfollowing on twitch
disaster oh my god
we should get away from this because
that's what imagine if we lose
followers on twitch because i put it up
on screen that would be really really
embarrassing
wowzer that's not good
we need to activate the follow bots
exactly it's time
it's time otherwise we're going to get
humiliated out of here
don't forget that we gave out an award
that was named after
a nazi werner von braun for operation
paperclip all right i will not forget
that
hal says just what do you think you're
doing dave dave i really think i'm
entitled to an answer to that question
all right arthur c
clarke stanley kubrick humor hopefully
the wind turbines on mars don't crap
out or this could be a disaster yeah a
fair point
gordon says hogan governor of maryland
is a good
reputation governor uh yeah he i mean
his reputation is not bad that's true
that's absolutely true no doubt
about it uh we just got
a massive dump of followers on twitch so
we are now down to the last
46. look at that we are down to the last
46 what will happen first the rover
lands
or we get to 80 000 followers on twitch
that's a really good question
i don't know i don't know the way things
are going it's anybody's guess
but uh we are in all seriousness
about to witness history uh 25 minutes
from the d
spin of the perseverance rover 41
minutes from touchdown
now down to its last uh four thousand
miles of altitude above the martian
surface
and uh yeah
what can we say it is just an incredible
incredible day
and tension building at jpl in
california
we are continuing to get coverage let's
take a listen team
to the uh to the launch cruise team uh
you've done everything we've asked for
right i mean
you battle anomalies you've you know
dealt with cessies you've done
everything
uh he delivered a healthy spacecraft uh
to the place that we want to go
um and she's right on target right he
did the last maneuver literally two
months ago
right this is pretty incredible in my
opinion and she's on with the right
information to help us land you know
doing the
founder update last night we're we're
ready to roll you've done everything
right
um and you've put up with us too right
you've put up with our eccentricities
and
the things we like to do in edl land so
i very much appreciate that
ladies and gentlemen we have touchdown
in the sense that
we are now at 80 000
twitch followers we have achieved it
and we were not to be held back by the
speed of light
we were not to be held back by what i
call unfollowed trolls ladies and
gentlemen we did it
we did it and we have breached 80 000
twitch i see people quickly
unsubscribing to try to get it down
below eighty thousand but i'm gonna
click away from it we did it
and that is all that matters we got to
eighty thousand now
on to one hundred thousand twitch
followers very very exciting
david do you support the artemis program
did you hear about joe biden supporting
the program can you do more space videos
i forget which one the artemis program
is
let me look that up nasa will land the
first
woman and next man on the moon by 2024
using innovative technologies yeah i do
i do
i think that even though we've been to
the moon going back makes sense because
we can learn
when we went to the moon technology was
nowhere near what it is today
and the opportunity to test these new
technologies
somewhere so close i think is a great
thing to be doing some people are so
lame they
say we've been to the moon why go back
to the moon give me a break guys
come on come on absolutely it makes
sense
david i heard ted cruz was seen on the
flight to mars apparently he was just
escorting the astronauts
yeah he's going to be right back uh he's
not really leaving texas when they are
in such uh rough situations
read on twitter about cruz the guy
worried about mexicans coming into our
country
to seek a better life is fleeing to
mexico to seek a better life
that's funny i tweeted something similar
to that here's ted cruz by the way
i had a similar notion but i worded it
differently
ted cruz is part of the party based on
claiming mexicans want to flee mexico
for the u.s
and he is literally fleeing the u.s to
mexico to get away from power outages
same idea same idea
can i briefly explain why republicans
are so hypocritical to compare the
damages of the protests last summer
in comparison to the insurrection these
things have nothing to do with each
other
the insurrection was a singular event
incited by the president over a lie
that he weaponized okay the violence
that we saw the
the main point of trump inspired
violence and violence was the main point
of it
what happened last summer i'm against
any violence and destruction of property
but what happened last summer was you
had disproportionately
bad faith actors who were not actually
trying to make any political point
taking advantage of protests over a
legitimate issue
not incited by a leader over a lie
there's i mean listen if you don't
understand the difference then i don't
know what to tell you
i'm not saying that the super chatter
doesn't understand i'm saying
if republicans want to play dumb and
pretend it's the same thing then
you know they they're probably beyond
help at this point in time
i don't understand why crazy trump
people just get over it and it's
probably because
they're in a cult and the only i guess
you mean a cult
and the only way to get out i don't know
they might need to get their brain to
fix it who trump again
yes absolutely they are an occult that's
for sure
david what do joe biden think about you
reaching 80 000 on twitch
he is reportedly fine with it yeah we
did reach 80
000 followers on twitch and it continues
to climb
and uh i think joe biden likes it i
think he does
we are now just 36 minutes from the
landing of the mars
perseverance rover and 20 minutes from
the d
spin phase at that point we are probably
going to go heavily into
the nasa coverage which we are standing
by for
and it's going to be extraordinarily
exciting to follow
is the space force involved in this nars
landing oh you know what
i actually have the uh
we have a space force song parody
which i can play for you this is a good
one
i don't believe space farce is part of
this hold on where is my space force
material
here it is this one's from jethro
bradley it's a good one
henceforth the men and women of the
united states
space force will be known as guardians
oh no
[Applause]
no it can't be
from our president a man who is actually
in space
right now space farce
[Music]
space is a warfighting domain
it comes to the outer reaches of space
yep you are that strength
if you rise on the wings of the dawn if
you settle
on the far side of the sea even if you
go
up to the heavens what the hell
his hand will guide you and his right
hand will hold you fast to defend
america and defend our freedom from
space
[Music]
anyway yeah the answer is no uh space
farce not
involved not involved in today's landing
as far as i'm aware
uh okay other super chats have you seen
the wall street bet
subreddit hilarious meme overloid
overload
i actually have been really enjoying
some of the memes on
the bitcoin subreddit uh what's one of
my favorites hold on let me see if i
can find it
uh there were there are really so many
i think i like this one this was a this
was a good meme
hold on a second
bitcoin's the only thing that doesn't go
down 51 000.
bitcoins are [ __ ] 51 000.
that 11 000 in august
what happens to all these wonderful
models if
ten billionaires just decide to buy one
billion dollars a bitcoin each and
announce we bought it
we're not ashamed of it we're gonna buy
more
all your models are destroyed completely
devastated
[Music]
anyway this one i like and then there is
uh
there was one other one hold on
oh i can't find it now no but there
there's so many i
am i am really oh hold on here it is
this one i love this this may be my
favorite
this is great
[Music]
don't you know bump it up
[Music]
i could really watch these all day i
don't know what it is about them i
really could watch those all
all day okay let's move on
um back to super chats when will we see
trump again in a public fashion
i don't know yet even yesterday in his
interviews he called in
so i don't know when we will see him why
aren't progressives as supportive of
human exploration of the moon or mars
like you
i didn't know progressives weren't
supportive of space exploration is that
true
they must because the republicans don't
seem supportive of it
and somebody is i i'm not i don't know
that i buy that premise
what are your thoughts on biden's new
deepak act it limits coupon codes to a
maximum of 30
off is this government overreach yeah
that's nanny's state nonsense i don't
need
the government telling me how big my
coupon codes can be i'll be the judge of
how big my coupon codes can be and if i
want to offer something like better 21
even though it exceeds 30 percent by
disgusting amounts
i'll be the judge of that and look at
these people taking advantage of it
matthias mariegaard has just signed up
at jointpakman.com using the coupon code
matt brown just signed up at
joinpackman.com
putting us at 44. we also just got
a drop-in of 20 more
twitch subscribers putting us at 64. i'm
talking people like
nerdies the real evil monkeys
short brief grim reaper
retalks jarvis tkd
connor sobe k mcgregor
uh the batch all of these really great
people coming in
i very much appreciate that all right we
are getting really really close to
landing time
we are now down to the last 30 minutes
until touchdown
d spin is happening in under 15 minutes
and we are going to be watching these
feeds we have multiple feeds from nasa
very closely let's listen
at this time let's continue our briefing
for the rest of the video
sure so after coming
out of edl start that's our
last real reinforcement of the state
that the vehicle was in
throughout much of crews and edl
approach
and it's our precursor to making
many more radical changes to the state
of the vehicle
matt wallace said it well the other day
this is edl is
kind of like a controlled disassembly of
the vehicle
right as we go through we need to uh
get rid of the things we don't need
anymore and get ready to put our wheels
on the ground
so um one of the final things that we're
doing here
is ensuring that our acs knowledge
is uh top notch we depend on acs
to pass an estimate of the
vehicle's attitude and rate of change
to edl and that's our starting point for
propagating down to the ground when we
come up
in the edl prep anchor
is when we'll take our the last state
from acs and we'll be propagating from
that point to the ground
until we get more knowledge from the
radar once we turn it on
[Music]
i can give a high level overview of
some of the events that were that are
going to transpire throughout edl
of course commentary will be
detailing this as we go through
and you'll hear a lot of members of the
edl team
calling out specific events as they
occur
and indicators as we see them but
to give everyone an idea of what we're
going to see
we will first start shortly here we'll
get
news that the vehicle has separated the
cruise stage
right since we no longer need that we
need to prepare for
entry into the atmosphere
after that we will indeed
start the entry process at this point
we're depending on the heat shield to
both protect the spacecraft
and help slow us down
we'll be gathering data from our
medley sensors and we'll be decelerating
rapidly at that point as we make our way
through the atmosphere
we'll be firing our drcs thrusters
that are in let's poke out the back of
the back shell
[Applause]
and this will allow us to steer our
trajectory
as we make our way through the
atmosphere
and this is one of the things that
allowed
msl the curiosity rover to uh
um to land where it did and we're
depending on the same type of entry
guidance
this time around to help get us very
close to our target
as we make our way through entry finish
the
finish our guided entry profile
we'll do a maneuver called heading
alignment where we
point toward the target and get ready to
deploy the parachute but before we
deploy the parachute
we need to get rid of a set
of balanced passes that have been
giving us a center of gravity or cg
offset
throughout the guided entry phase so
these are called
the uh this is sort of a media briefing
on the nasa clean feed we also have
uh the kind of more produced feed let's
listen to what's going on here deploy
the parachute
i'll put the same deploy to parachute
we need to get rid of a set of balanced
passes
that have been giving us a
center of gravity or cg offset
throughout the guided entry phase so
these are called
the the enter balance masses we also
call this maneuver
sucker sufr or straighten up and fly
right
so we'll go ahead and eject those masses
when we get a trigger from the gnc
system
telling us that we're at the appropriate
range to the target to do so
as soon as we deploy those we will
no longer have a cd offset and
we'll be ready to deploy the parachute
17 seconds later
i would encourage them to keep the cg
offset just a little longer than they're
planning on it they probably know more
than i do i don't know
um i i do want to say thank you to
patrick o'neill for signing up at
jointpacman.com thanks to xander ensland
for signing up
thanks to matt walker who's our newest
member and also sandra shell
all of whom signed up at joinpackman.com
we are really getting down to the end
here my friends
we are now down to 24 minutes to touch
down and nine minutes
from d spin 24 minutes to touchdown nine
minutes from d spin
down to its last 1900 miles of elevation
of altitude
and 3 500 miles from the landing site
sort of like you know europe to the east
coast of the united states one with one
could say
um and we are watching nasa coverage and
we are getting
excitingly close excitingly close
ozaji says it's weird hearing them talk
about edl since the english defense
league is a pretty nasty far-right group
in the u.s
yeah i should do a once a week space
news
segment that's an idea
jonathan says no i'm sure progressives
do support human exploration but what i
meant was they don't voice it as much as
you or they don't seem as excited
that you'd have to ask them that you'd
have to ask them very exciting
stuff uh from my perspective
thanks to megawatts for signing up via
twitch
as well as koirai grim reaper and uh
oh i think that's it three folks
which i very much appreciate we are in
the tent within 10 minutes
of the d spin phase and it looks like
what they're talking about now
really doesn't why is it still so
difficult well it's
well because it's involved thousands and
thousands i think hundreds of thousands
of lines of code
we there there is uh there's 79
pyrotechnic devices
each have to work perfectly one critical
wire short or one
key thing mechanism that doesn't work or
breaks and it's mission over
and so it's you know and and so and and
it's very love the peanuts here
we're not perfect mistakes can be made
um
we each count on each other to to find
uh our own mistakes
and we work very hard to
to learn from the mistakes of the past
um
we've had many failures half remind
people roughly half little
around half of the missions to mars over
history have failed
um and so it's it's it's that could
happen today too even though we've had a
nice wonderful
string of successes in the united states
it's still
a a still a bit of a gamble a gamble
that we've we have hoped that we have we
have aired in the side of luck
and and and we've stacked the dice that
stacked the deck
and uh loaded the dice to make this
thing succeed loaded dice
but um if we do if we do fail and
something bad happens today
i can tell you we're going to learn it
we'll have the data to tell us what
happened
we'll know why we'll figure it out and
and if we
are allowed we will pick ourselves up
and get us back on the horse
and if congress and nasa allow we will
try again
as we always do we will learn from our
mistakes right
and what are the possible scenarios we
could be looking at today
well there's things things like uh one
of the key
stressful elements for all of us is
parachute inflation
but just even separating from the cruise
stage is a pretty major event
lots of devices have to work properly um
certainly on the heat shield separation
uh getting getting the the descent
engine started there's no less than
than us 16 rocket motors that have to
work uh one two
eight to control during entry another
eight to control it during landing
i said it's a lot of stuff and it all
has to work and guess what
we haven't done this before with this
vehicle ever this is this first attempt
to actually land
we can't try this on earth we can't do
uh we don't have test pilots to try it
out on this planet before the big show
so this vehicle is doing it for the
first time we've done the best testing
we can do in bits and pieces
but you know it's it's as best as we
could do and and uh
but i think our team is up to it we've
this team is the best it's a diverse
intelligent amazing group of people uh
people from all over the world who
worked on this
not just here in california but all over
nasa contributors
from aerospace universities countries
around the world
it is just an incredible remarkable
engineering achievement
and i am just so proud of this team
thanks rob now
let's listen back into mission control
all right we're about 14 minutes from
entry interface
the vehicle is currently preparing
the heat rejection system that has kept
the thermal system cool inside the
aeroshell for about the last six months
this will allow the stiff cuff to more
easily cut the line
in upcoming cruise stage separation
which is under four minutes now
it's happening
that's this they are talking about i
believe the d spin we have now
enabled the rover pyrobus
that's the pyrotechnic uh system uh that
that was
powering off the cruise stage devices
and these are the
these are the things in the cruise stage
that will that we no longer need
with the pyrotechnic system working we
can you can we can
explode advice if you're just joining us
we are now a full
just 20 minutes from landing 19 and a
half minutes four minutes from the d
spin that takes place before the actual
sort of like approach phase
happens i do want to say thanks to
travis
kitlitz for signing up at joinpakman.com
your new member number 72 today
also want to say thanks to pamela
goodman the real paco and scarlett
charlie for signing up via twitch number
7374 and 75.
uh tim critt wants to know if i'd
consider taking a trip to nars
if we managed to build a nars colony i
would as long as it was a short trip
uh no no question whatsoever we are now
within the three minute mark of the d
spin anchor is complete
we will see the next anchor in
approximately three minutes
this guy's very excited
okay we are currently 12 and a half
minutes from entry interface
we are coming up on cruise stage
separation in two minutes and 20 seconds
wow what's happening now rob okay we'll
just we're just waiting this
the the rover is completely in charge
it's doing all the things we've taught
it how to do i think rob's too excited
over and over and over again this team
has spent
24 hours a day seven days a week testing
this thing
for years and and and so this is uh this
is really the culmination of all that
work so
this vehicle is is gonna is getting
ready to push that cruise stage away
uh once it gets pushed away um it it the
entry system the rover inside with the
rover is still in charge
is going to get ready to take the
vehicle turn it to the right orientation
and
aim it to mars and and uh and prepare
for entering the atmosphere
wow what a day
this won't be long um be prepared for
this event taking about a minute and a
half
from mistake to separation
minutes 20 seconds from entry interface
wow
okay so it's about 10 minutes from
cruising separation until it enters the
top of the atmosphere
from then on and out things happen here
tones telemetry will have stopped
telecom is confirming that the
spacecraft has switched to broadcasting
tones these tones are received directly
from perseverance but have
very limited information content we
won't receive
real-time information until about
9-10 minutes from now once the mars
reconnaissance orbiter
starts relaying information from
perseverance we are under a minute from
cruise stage separation
about 10 and a half minutes from entry
interface one minute from separation now
it's getting exciting i have to admit i
am quite anxious
uh but very hopeful this machine is
going to do what we asked for
the heartbeat tones
there's no more ones and zeros coming
it's just the vehicle telling us it's
still alive
we're at tones
hopefully auspicious t kitlet says i
just joined the coupon code is crazy i
think it guaranteed the successful rover
landing can you confirm
i absolutely hope so
and thanks to dean tackett for signing
up on my website as well dean what a
perfectly timed new membership
d spin should now be happening
cruise stage separation apparently
taking place
they have indication that cruise stage
separation has been confirmed by the
spacecraft
there it is
wow good start in one minute press
advances landing software will wake up
and begin the no preparations for entry
the first action it will do is to fire
warm-up pulses with the
entry thrusters these pulses ensure that
the spacecraft gets the thrust that it
wants during entry interface
we're about nine minutes from entry
interface
as you guys can tell this app is not
exactly synced
with the video the vehicle is on its own
it's kind of it's turning itself into
the direction of
facing the heat shield toward mars and
uh
and will eventually uh uh hitting the
top of the atmosphere we're not far away
this is going to go very quickly from
here on out wow it's happening
friends it's happening
they are ejecting masses that's
confirmation that we got shadowed by the
cruise stage as it
passed through our beam to the earth
telecom indicated actually that we could
see a signal that the crew stage went
between
the perseverance entry capsule and earth
so we saw a little blip
uh the data stream indicating the
crusade separation
we have confirmation that the vehicle
has started warming up those entry
thrusters
normal pulses have begun very strong
pulses happening we're about eight and a
half minutes
from atmospheric entry
at this point the spacecraft is trying
to stop
its spin from the cruise two revolutions
per minute down to zero
and then we'll turn to its desired
orientation from
entry it will separate
the two balance masks that have kept it
balanced during all of cruise
this will allow the entry capsule to
have lift when
it enters the atmosphere the competition
the effect has turned
to the desire entry attitude
we are about seven and a half minutes
from entry interface
what a day the vehicle is pointed in the
right direction
thrusters are warmed up and doing their
job
and now if we've spun down from the
two revolutions per minute that the
vehicle had the whole way to all the way
to mars is a spin stabilized spacecraft
and then from here on out it's going to
just be a bullet
and it's going to control its orient
orientation and attitude
via rockets on the back of that points
carrier lock
sorry the dte from the
radio science from green bank reports
carrier lock
you see the carrier on the delic
flight level one we are continuing to
wait
for entry interface for about six
minutes and 45
seconds from entry interface we have
confirmation from
greenback that they are receiving direct
earth telemetry via that
path nice the spacecraft performance is
currently
transmitting heartbeat tones these tones
indicate that
perseverance is operating normally and
has nothing significant to report
that's good as expected we're currently
just over six minutes
from entry interface
okay and now we wait
as soon as we get to the top of the
atmosphere the atm will be very quickly
which is the entry point it won't be
very long before
the the atmosphere will start getting
thicker and thicker it's going very
quickly
at a fairly steep angle of 15 degrees
into the atmosphere as it starts to slow
down
just under about five and a half minutes
from entry interface
we're still receiving heartbeat tones we
expect to continue receiving heartbeat
tones until about five minutes after
entry
at that time perseverance will be no
longer in view of our antennas here on
earth
about 90 seconds prior to entry the mars
reconnaissance orbiter
should begin receiving telemetry from
perseverance
and streaming it to earth in near real
time
there are a few expected short outages
such as when we have a plasma back out
or when we enter the peak heating
phase aside from these outages caused by
the plasma blackout
antenna switching or high dynamic events
spacecraft events
we should have telemetry until about 90
seconds
after landing a plasma blackout
is when the signal from perseverance
isn't strong enough to make it through
the superheated
super fast air flowing around the
spacecraft
all the way down to earth once the
temperature drops below that peak
heating we do reacquire the signal from
perseverance
we are currently about four and a half
minutes from entry interface
right perseverance continues to report
heartbeat tones indicating everything
is nominal okay
what we're looking for now is where mars
reconstance orbiter should be in view
soon of our vehicle and be able to
listen to ones and zeros coming from a
separate radio
that's really designed to talk between
spacecraft camera reports the electro
radio is powered on ready to receive
signals from the lander
there it is mro is ready and less
enabled
and waiting for the to hear from our
rover constance's
orbiter has reported that it's ready to
receive the signal from perseverance
it should be in a few minutes here we're
just flight local one from entry
interface
we don't need these one to zeroes as
swati said
but to land safely but we really need it
for our own
health and well-being today to keep our
nerves into control around this time
a second spacecraft maven should begin
picking up telemetry from perseverance
and will continue to record that
telemetry until several minutes post
landing
we won't get that data for several hours
after landing
as it's being recorded and then will be
forwarded to earth
later we are continuing to receive
heartbeat tones
indicating that everything is nominal
we're currently at
about three minutes until entry
interface
very soon we'll be getting ones and
zeros i hope from our radio on the rover
thanks to grant turner for the
membership appreciate it grant
the entry interface is nothing more than
just an arbitrary place in the sky that
we've defined to be above the atmosphere
but but from that point on uh there's
definitely uh
atmosphere and above it there isn't
there are two minutes from entry
interface cartridge it
will transmit heartbeat tones indicating
everything
is nominal
so the tones can tell us whether
something is bad or not is happening so
so far the heartbeat
is doing well so the vehicle thinks it's
help it's
in good shape to land which is a great
sign
we're just under two minutes from entry
interface as it gets closer to mars
presidents is actually being pulled in
by gravity and accelerating
by the time price range reaches entry
interface point
she should be going just under 5.4
kilometers per second
we had about 90 seconds from entry
interface
and standing by for mars reconnaissance
orbiter to pick up
the telemetry
right
down really to the wire here
we are one minute from entry interface
they may find the 11 780 votes on mars
they may be there under a rock or
something
in receive mode we have confirmation
that
the reconnaissance orbiter is now
relaying data from perseverance
we're about 30 seconds from entry
interface
programs is going about 5.2 kilometers
per second and
is about 190 kilometers altitude above
the surface of mars
confirm your depth data flow
we have data flow
seconds from entry interface
5.3 kilometers per second and an
altitude of
150 numbers from the surface of mars
we have confirmation of entry interface
it's in the atmosphere
you're going 5.3 kilometers per second
at an altitude of about 120 kilometers
from the surface of mars
the rover has made it to martian
atmosphere it is now within
and controlled by subject to martian
gravity
waiting until it begins feeling the
atmosphere
down once there is enough atmosphere it
will
start controlling its path to the
landing target
navigation is also confirming that we
can see a little bit of that slowdown
of the atmosphere on
the perseverance entry capsule right
our current velocity is about 5.36
kilometers per second and an altitude of
about 67
kilometers from the surface we are
probably seeing mro plasma blackout at
this point
we have a plasma blackout or plasma
you know
the shoot will soon be deploying right
now
has lost luck president
we have indications that perseverance is
now performing bank reversals
in the atmosphere these are the steps in
order to
control its distance to the landing
target
press events has just passed through the
point of maximum deceleration
and has indicated that it felt
approximately
10 earth g's of deceleration wow
camera is locked again
yes yes yes yes we saw a small outage
uh of the uhf telemetry from mars
reconnaissance orbiter
during that peak heating phase likely
caused
by the plasma blackout perseverance is
still continuing to perform bank
reversals
i know people are ruining the party by
saying that with the with the many
minute delay
because of the speed of light between
mars that this is probably already over
we're getting the data now so we're
experiencing it now guys that's what
matters
perseverance is going about one
kilometer per second
at an altitude of about 16 kilometers
from the surface of mars we have entered
heading alignment which means
preservance is no longer
trying to control the distance to mars
but ends
to the target on mars but instead is
flying
straight to the target and velocity has
slowed down dramatically just in
that in the last minute going from mach
12 to mach 4 as you can see in the
bottom middle there
now down to mach 2.7 continuing to slow
down
shoot not yet deployed though right they
will tell us when the shoot is deployed
i'm sure velocity
is about 550 meters per second
at an altitude of about 15 kilometers
from the surface
amarillo's reporting good telemetry lock
we are coming upon the straighten up we
are starting to straighten up and fly
right maneuver
where the spacecraft will jettison the
entry balance masses
there it is in preparation for parachute
deploy and to roll over to give the
radar a better look at the ground
telling me it's been deployed it hasn't
as we've received the data
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and parachutes
open
deceleration in velocity our current
velocity is 450 meters per second at an
altitude of about 12 kilometers from the
surface of mars
chute is out
first advance is now slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated
under mach 1. both the radar and the
cameras to get their first look at the
surface
current velocity is 145 meters per
second and an altitude of about
10 km 9 and a half kilometers above the
surface wow
this is it
they've confirmed it mars is spherical
it's not flat
yes yes yes
now has radar lock on the ground current
velocity is about 100 meters per second
6.6 kilometers of the circuit very close
last six kilometers amazing what wall
street bets has been able to do
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute
we are coming up on the initialization
of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity is
about 90 meters per second at an
altitude of 4.2 kilometers
people pointing out that that's not live
video we know
we know we have confirmation that the
lander vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of training relative navigation
it's finding the spot that's what that
means
we have timing of the landing engines
current philosophy is 83 meters per
second at about 2.6 kilometers from the
surface mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated we are currently
performing the divert maneuver
current velocity is about 75 meters per
second at an altitude
of about a kilometer off the surface of
mars one kilometer
here in safety bravo we have
completed our train relative navigation
current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude of about
300 meters
wow of ours that means we're 10 seconds
away
300 divided by 30. yeah that's ten
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means we are
conducting the sky crane about to
protect the cycling maneuver
we've lost direct earth tones tones are
gone
as expected skype maneuver has started
about 20 meters wow 20 meters
are we down i think we're down
uaf is good
[Applause]
they did it folks
at this point the seven stage has flown
away to save distance
perseverance is continuing to transmit
direct what a day
[Applause]
oh my god oh
my still getting telemetry from the
lander an
eight-month voyage roughly
ending exactly as scheduled ah
and soon we should have imagery so
exciting
the team is beside themselves it's so
surreal
stay tuned we might get some pictures
pictures potentially just a few minutes
away
hd video probably tomorrow i think
so much has been riding on this
and the coronavirus now has gone just
heard the news that
orbital perseverance is alive on the
surface of mars
we have seen the completion of edl 3000
copy activity that is as expected
all right folks they did it
[Music]
okay all right
just the start of the mission of course
we've just heard the news that
perseverance is alive
on the surface of mars congratulations
to the mission
and looks like we have some more news in
it looks like we're getting the first
image first pictures here take a look at
the first image
this is ol3 i have uh
the target point on the map when you are
ready
we are ready ol3 go for it
is this it is this the landing shot what
they saw coming down
flight i'll be uh moving in showing you
the
safe zone that we've landed in
there it is the first image firm
perseverance on the surface of mars
now it comes from the engineering
cameras known as the hazard camera
this camera is mainly used to help the
rover drive safely around mars
not exactly 4k higher resolution photos
later in the day
right but there it is
thanks to liz and greg for the
memberships i see you guys i appreciate
[Music]
it
the first images coming in from mars
already
steve stand by for steve
standing by for steve
[Music]
you did you led the team you made
[Music]
are we anticipating more pictures do we
know
oh another picture second image is in
[Applause]
okay this is these these we have a
camera in the front and at rear
uh it's uh it's it's they're near the
ground so these are pretty close you can
see the wheels there
uh and and and they're a little dirty
because we've got
glass covers over these these cameras
but uh we took these
seconds after landing so so they're
still dust in the air from our landing
event
uh so this is this is happening um uh
you know this happened just seconds ago
just arrived
and this is really amazing
[Applause]
and uh we even know where we landed this
is the most amazing thing the vehicle
has told us
where it's landed because figured it out
you know this is a sign
nasa works nasa works and when we put
our arms together
and our hands together and our brains
together we can succeed
this is what nasa does this is what we
can do as a country
right all of the problems we have we
need to work together
to do these kinds of things and make
success happen
two pictures now coming in landing
taking place about 10 minutes ago
this is the perseverance rover is the
acting
administrator of nasa steve jurisic
steve
welcome and congratulations
hey thank you what an amazing day and
how does it feel to have another rover
on mars
uh it's amazing um to have perseverance
join curiosity
on mars and what what a just a credit to
the team
i mean just what an amazing team
to work through all the adversity
that goes and all the challenges that go
with landing a rover on mars
plus the challenges of covid and
um and just an amazing accomplishment
and what does this mean for nasa and its
future plans
so for robotic exploration know every
time we
execute a mission with new instruments
we discover new things
and things we never thought we would
discover so hey we'll get back to this
by the way
just as a joke i i twit i tweeted an
obvious joke of a tweet
you've got to see how triggered some
people are by this i tweeted joe biden
has only been president a few weeks and
he already got us to mars incredible
obviously i'm kidding but some of these
responses are pretty funny
uh i think he invented space
um greatest president ever
space force [ __ ] okay that's
interesting
are you joking or being serious just in
case this is me explaining this mission
was launched like in july
come on guys i know launched seven
months ago under trump
though are we actually giving him credit
for this or is this sarcasm i'm confused
uh anyway yeah it's obviously a joke
guys i'm just kidding around
just a joke it's going to give us
properties
size and properties of dust particles
because when we send people we're going
to have to deal with that dust
and just it's just this is just an
incredible mission because of the
science and the technology
and then caching samples for a mars
sample return mission
that will be an amazing mission the
first round trip
to mars and back and bringing those
samples cached by perseverance back to
earth to
examine with state-of-the-art equipment
in our laboratories here on earth
we have so much to look forward to and
we also have a student question coming
in from landon
all right guys we did it it's been a
long day this was already the second
stream so we are going to wrap
our coverage here but i really
appreciate everybody who joined me
everybody who helped us get to 80 000
followers on twitch
and we have so much more to come uh
thanks everybody
great to be here with all of you make
sure you're following on twitch and
subscribed for free on youtube so you'll
be notified of future
streams everybody take care and new
clips publishing now on youtube
you